patrick erieau bonsoir bonsoir ci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur rt
france alors on le disait le ministre d
outre-mer est attendu jeudi en
martinique il arrive ce soir en
guadeloupe
il parle d'une situation extrêmement
grave c'est ce que vous constatez c'est
ce que constate aussi les médecins
libéraux dans leurs cabinets en
martinique
bien sûr les médecins libéraux font ce
qu'ils peuvent
et c'est de prendre en charge le maximum
de patients qu'aux vide pour éviter les
prendre en charge à domicile
déjà pour leur donner des conseils
éviter l'hospitalisation
nous sommes confrontés malheureusement
un état d'extrême tension
nous n'avons même plus d'oxygène les
prestataires sont en rupture de stock
donc les limitations donc sont
drastiques pour maintenir à domicile il
faut de l'oxygène pour essayer d'éviter
des saturations avant d'envisager
l'hospitalisation
donc vous voyez que lamont est déjà très
fragilisé heureusement on a aussi parlé
avec les infirmières ont travaillé en
collaboration avec des infirmières
libérales
l'hôpital est en extrême tension avec
des places limitées avec des pertes de
chance pour le dire franchement pour les
patients parce que si saturé il n'y a
plus assez de matériel place et
personnel un personnel en souffrance et
c'est la première fois donc merci à la
solidarité nationale de nous emporter
des renforts parce que les équipes sont
extrêmement fatigué sous tension et nous
manquons de matériel donc le matériel et
est nécessaire elle et rend toujours
humains sont indispensables on pense
j'ai effectivement 240 personnels qui
doivent pas arriver aux antilles ça va
être suffisant selon vous c'est une
première vague donc déjà la première ils
vont arriver uniquement pour reforcer
l'hôpital donc puisque je vous ai exposé
que l'hôpital et c'est sous tension mais
faut pas oublier que l'hôpital ne bois
que 5% de la population les you really
des bus en ville
donc il faudra vraiment avoir un
maillage avec un effort de tous donc
renforcer la prise en charge en libéral
permet aussi d'éviter les
hospitalisations et de réserve
l'hôpital aux cas graves donc c'est
vraiment une collaboration de tous les
acteurs de terrain qu'ils soient
libéraux ou hospitaliers
il faut que la population prenne
conscience que le moyen aussi pour
lutter de façon efficace et la
vaccination nous avons un taux de
vaccination quand même dramatique
puisque nous sommes seulement à 18 24 %
de schéma complet en martinique dont
c'est un taux très faible et
malheureusement nous constatons quand
même 11 décès en 24 heures en 48 heures
par dont 35 les dernières semaines donc
c'est vraiment très très inquiétant
justement cette question de la
vaccination obligatoire elle fait débat
en france notamment dans votre
département vous rappeliez les chiffres
un peu moins de 22 % de la population
majeure vacciner en martinique il ya des
voix qui demandent que les recherches
s'orientent aussi sur les traitements de
la maladie quelle est votre regard de
médecins sur cette question justement
les traitements de la maladie déjà la
première
la première mesure c'est pas la voir
donc si on est vaccinés on évite quand
même la dissémination et ensuite si on
est vaccinés on n'a à un kobe qui est
beaucoup plus faible
il faut bien se rendre compte qu
actuellement en martinique les hôpitaux
sont saturés de personnes non vaccinées
aucune personne en réanimation des
vaccinés donc les débats de dire le coc
vide
la vaccination oui non il faut quand
même bien se rendre compte que la
vaccination évite le passage en
réanimation et évite de décéder
donc le but c'est pas mourir il entend
tout ton tout vaccin vous avez des
personnes qui peuvent être atteintes
mais avec des formes très très atténuée
il faut bien se rendre compte que
si nous avons une population fragile
population quand même âge et avec des
prévalences de maladies chroniques très
importante 10% de diabel une
hypertension importante donc il faut ce
sont des pathologies qui sont à risque
avec plus de malheureusement de
comorbidité et on sait très bien qu'avec
la qu'ovide on s'expose à des fins
beaucoup plus grave
donc là on nous avons à déplorer quand
même un jeune de 30 ans qui est décédé
du coup ça c'est en parallèle de la
vaccination à cette décision de confiner
la martinique de manière très stricte
selon vous il n'y avait pas le choix
vous entendre ce soir
bien sûr on n'avait pas le choix et
merci d'avoir pris ces décisions elle
était indispensable
les mesures de les mesures de limitation
go permettre d'enrayer cette vague
il faut bien se rendre compte qu
actuellement nous ne sommes pas au pic
de la marque
donc on sait que l'hôpital on passe la
bague le sommet de laval sera donc un
jour donc je sais que les personnes qui
vont arriver en renfort et merci à ce
renfort nationale y aura roulement et
donc encore pendants fin je pense que
quatre semaines qu'est ce que vous
appelez pour y aller et je vous en prie
pour avoir aussi aventures des libéraux
nous pourrons aussi avoir un renfort en
médecine libérale pour soulager
parce qu'il faut pas oublier comme les
libéraux sont les acteurs qui sont sur
le front
c'est les petits soldats du front 1
depuis le début vous avez les infirmiers
qui sont là au chevet des patients aussi
avec les médecins libéraux qui prennent
en charge et faut bien aussi se rendre
compte que plus vous aurez de
pathologies qui seront pris en charge en
libéral avec éviter justement toutes les
pathologies chroniques qui doivent
continuer à être soigné pour ne pas
avoir de peine de chance ne pas faire
comprenant la première vague ou de plus
personne ne venait consulter les
médecins et après eux des catastrophes
avec des retards
traitement des bana dit aggravée avec
une présence ya encore beaucoup plus
difficile nous sommes à l'umih km avec
des moyens beaucoup plus faible donc
merci aux renforts mais il faut que la
population prenne conscience et de tous
les efforts qui doivent être faits par
tout à chacun chacun son dico merci
beaucoup à un tri caillou d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce soir sur la
france je le rappelle vous êtes
présidente de l'union régionale des
médecins libéraux de martinique